c'est par le journal officiel paru hier
que l'on a appris un relèvement de 23%
de l'allocution la location pardon de
salaire majoré cette mesure intéresse
environ 800 mille personnes un autre
décret porte à 553 francs la base
mensuelle de calcul des prestations
familiales à partir du 1er août
il s'agit donc d'une augmentation de
près de 13%
une série d'augmentations des
différentes prestations familiales
c'est une des applications du plan de
revalorisation de la condition des
familles qui avaient été adoptées on
s'en souvient par le conseil des
ministres du 20 juin dernier la base
mensuelle de calcul des prestations
familiales est porté à 553 france ce qui
signifie une augmentation de 12 9%
ce relèvement tient compte de
l'augmentation du coût de la vie du 1er
mars 73 au 1er mars 74 qui était de 12
2%
les 0 7% supplémentaires sont fixés dans
le but de faire participer les familles
à la croissance de l'activité économique
du pays
l'allocation de salaire unique parce 217
francs 60 à 140 487 une majoration de
23%
ces augmentations vont bénéficier à 800
mille familles
le montant de l'allocation aux
handicapés adultes est portée de 120
francs à 150 francs par mois ce qui fait
une augmentation de 20 % en six mois
enfin l'allocation spéciale de rentrée
scolaire nouvellement créée et sera
versé en octobre et les 210 francs par
enfant scolarisé de 6 à 16 ans est
destiné aux familles qui touche au moins
l'une des allocations familiales et dont
les ressources imposables sont
inférieures à treize mille huit cent
cinquante francs par an pour un enfant
cette allocation sera versée
automatiquement toutes les familles qui
ont touché les allocations normalement
nous derniers vont la toucher sans avoir
à faire une demande supplémentaire